- More news out of The Supreme Court,
The Supreme Court has basically denied
all of the remaining election lawsuits.
So those of you who thought you could
undo the election of Joe Biden,
I'm sorry to say those hopes
are completely dashed at this point.
In a raft of one line
orders The Supreme Court
has basically done away with
all of these election lawsuits.
This includes Kelly versus Pennsylvania,
which was the strongest of all of these
very, very weak claims,
You have a King versus Whitmer
which was the Michigan crack in case,
you have Lin Wood's crazy Georgia case,
Kelly Ward's crazy case in Arizona
and Trump's crazy case in Wisconsin.
I've done lots of videos on how crazy
all of these lawsuits were,
but now they are done.
They took their shot at The
Supreme Court and it's over.
So subscribe or I'll see you in court,
unless you're trying to litigate
all of these election things,
in which case I won't see you in court
because you were dismissed.